well
guys last night was an
interesting time to be a mandalorian fan
to say the least
[Laughter]
what happened something happened yeah
we're going to talk about
two things today oh good gina carano
being fired from lucasfilm and the other
thing is some last of us casting
i think uh you know we keep the last of
us one really short
it's really fun so we'll just we'll kick
off with that
it's going to be really brief and then
we'll talk about the gina caron
situation so with the last of us show on
hbo
i'm very much excited for this and the
casting has got me even
that much more excited pedro pascal has
been cast
to play joel in this series i think this
is great casting it's fascinating
casting because
he's perfect for the role and it's also
a weird
typecast
a somber traumatized dude who has to
take an important child on a perilous
journey will regain love and humanity
within him
through this relationship with this
child
and he doesn't have to wear a helmet i
saw this casting news and i was like oh
yeah that makes perfect sense
this is in line with his trajectory up
until yeah like this is danjarin
in a lot of ways actually and now he's
gonna not wanna wear the beard and
that's gonna be the new controversy
it's the deal with this sci-fi world
yeah he was in game of thrones and then
they got bella ramsay from game of
thrones who played the anna mormont cast
as ellie in the series so you got this
game of thrones reunion in the hbo
world i loved her in game of thrones and
ellie
is you know pretty mature for someone of
her age and we'll have to see her i'm
like i thought she was awesome in that
show but ellie's a
very different character whereas pedro
pascal you're like oh yeah you can
totally do that yeah
pedro basco easily can pull that off her
i have a lot of faith she'll
she'll pull it off but you know just
with the creator of chernobyl behind it
the fact that you know neil druckmann is
heavily involved with this series as
well don't worry save your abbey
complaints till we get to season two
i'm ready uh but right now in terms of
this immediate casting i think it's
brilliant i love it i'm very much
excited for it pedro pascal has very
different political views
than gina carano segway into the topic
so if you guys haven't heard the news
not sure where you've been at
but gina carano was uh fired from
lucasfilm
and let go by her talent agency
yesterday she put out this post
now some people are saying she wrote it
to me it looks like a shared post
bottom line it was taken um
not very well to say the least the
reaction the implication that was
mainly received was that she's comparing
being part of the conservative party the
republican party
to being a jew during the holocaust
times you know she's got her defenders
who are like that's not what she was
saying no
what she was saying is that this is the
start of that and even that it does not
bode well for a lot of people
yeah like bottom line you just shouldn't
be making this comparison right and
there are people who got mad for the
jewish community and then there are
people who are in the jewish community
who especially
did not like this at all isn't john
favreau jewish
yes but he's fine
he doesn't care you might want to cover
your ears because
if you don't like politics in your
videos well
this is all political all this is
politics
out of my political stories yeah exactly
now we're doing our video late i really
wanted to see how i felt about things
this wasn't actually an
easy thing for me to fall on i decided
to
read a whole bunch of articles and i
also listened to a bunch of videos as
well
i wanted to really hear both arguments
of things both sides i did my absolute
best to hear both sides because it's
easy to kind of just
find the outlet that only supports
your opinion it's really easy to fall
under that
chamber what i've discovered is that
majority
of the media news outlets that are like
entertainment websites
are very much anti-gina carano and very
much
like yes get her out of here good
riddance and then you go on youtube
and on youtube not all i'd say some of
the biggest ones though
and i listen them all from beginning to
end are very much
cancel your disney plus subscription you
know that's they're trying to get that
trending now
uh this was not the right call this is
messed up very much
against this move this is feeding more
into the divide of the left and the
right
common consensus it's very easy to draw
when you look at both videos if you're
on the left side
you're probably cool with this probably
i'm gonna underline that probably
if you're on the right side you're
probably not cool with this at all if
you don't really give a [ __ ] about
politics and you know like does this
doesn't really affect your opinion you
might not even care about this situation
at all so like if you look at the common
consensus from the side of the left they
have found her to be racist
transphobic they found her to help
spread lies about the election helped
spread lies about
mass being anti-master all those things
if you look at the side of the right
they really come to her defense
obviously for some of the main political
things and then the common consensus on
the right is that she's not actually
transphobic what she was going after
were the people who she found were
bullying her not the trans community
itself
but the people who were attacking her as
who she was actually provoking
and making like those beep bop boop
things about just to
attack and provoke them not the trans
community themselves either way it still
provoked the trans community you know
wonder woman and then a lot of people
were also saying she wasn't doing a
one-to-one
comparison of with that post that she
put out yesterday
about that either way i still don't
think it flies by well i feel like if
you can get confused
in this way it probably was a bad post
to reshare you want a clear idea i feel
like a lot of the defense
does come down to she didn't mean it
this way
yeah so at very least it seems like her
judgment may be a bit spotty
well it's like she doesn't really give
interviews on it she'll share a lot of
things which
will reflect her opinion but a lot of
what she puts out are
shared posts an occasional tweet of her
own
vocabulary of her own text and i think
that's all important to factor in
because
this is all an accumulation of what led
to her being fired
this is not a isolated incident off of
that one post that she put out
yesterday and this is very political and
here's the thing with the politics
it's pretty easy to see both sides left
and right
they each have a very similar view of
each other
each side thinks the other is crazy each
side thinks the other
are cultists each side thinks the other
are destroying
this country or the world each side
thinks the other believes lies
like this is the way it always goes it's
the same thought and behavior just
directed at two polar oppositions each
side thinks they play victim card all
the time
like it's the it's the way it it just is
right now
and maybe that will never change i know
right now if you made it to this point
in the video probably a large chunk of
you guys we're not in the
gray area of this a lot of you guys are
probably yes very much
on one side or the other when it comes
to this particular topic here's my
initial reaction to when i found out she
was fired
well i'm not surprised not with what
i've heard about
the behind the scenes of her recent
trajectory in the public eye
yeah and her having talks with disney
and then want to talk to her because
this
to me it's like people bring up the
freedom of speech argument here
censorship and all that she has freedom
of speech she still has her twitter
she can still make whatever post she
wants to make the thing though is
freedom of speech does not
equate to immunity to consequences if
that makes sense
i hope it does i think it should
and private tech giants follow freedom
of speech ideals but they
have their own limited version of that
for their platforms and whatnot too
disney's a big company and
they have clearly taken more of a
liberal
approach when it comes to these things
whether to talk about the right or left
they've clearly taken an approach that
leans more to the left
just look at a lot of statements that
come out recently the reason i'm
bringing it up because yeah
people are right pedro pascal can insult
trump
all he wants chris evans mark ruffalo
a whole bunch of people who can publicly
go against
the right and they seem to suffer
absolutely zero consequences
to attacking the right side whereas uh
gina carano was constantly getting
herself in hot water
for being someone who's a supporter of
the conservative section of things and
disney themselves
they're not a fan of controversy they
they don't like controversy
do they placate more to the liberal side
of things i'm not going to lie to you
guys and say they
don't it's all over their recent movies
very much
do yeah they're very much on the edge of
like let's
get all as much inclusivity as we can
into our movies appeal to the widest
range of people yes
that's why i'm saying it's not
surprising they would fire her because
it's not like they they're not within
their rights or
legality to fire them they have the
freedom she's
she has the freedom to say whatever she
wants they also have the freedom to fire
her if they want to fire her and it
doesn't have to be even for
this purpose it could be for just we
want to go a different direction
with you that's obviously not why they
fired her
i'm just saying that people can get
fired for reasons that are nowhere near
as consequential as this
some people are coming in and arguing
that well just because she's sharing her
voice and her opinion on
which side of the political party she
falls on she's not inciting violence is
she
honestly here's the there's the sad fact
of that
it doesn't matter when it comes to
disney maybe there are people behind the
scenes who keep their mouth shut about
their political point of views
but the public image of them
is very liberal left-leaning
family-friendly so when you've got
someone who is very much right-leaning
who every time they say
or do something on twitter over the last
year
lands them in some get this woman fire
trending spot yeah it does not bode well
for them at least in their eyes it does
not do well for them like
i don't agree with like on my personal
opinion i don't agree with
what gina carano was putting out i don't
agree with it same time though
still able to enjoy the mandalorian i
was like you never heard us
bring that up when we were watching
season two all this was happening
during season two and i was like i can
still enjoy the mandalorian yeah
it's one of those things where it's
interesting to see when the consequences
become real and it's one of those things
where if they
kept her on i probably would have maybe
been able to go yeah okay she's got some
bad takes in real life or takes that i
at least don't subscribe to but hey yeah
she's a supporting character from my
views it doesn't seem like she's
actively going out to hurt people you
know so
whatever but at the same time i mean
especially if the reports are true that
disney
didn't even give her the james gunn
treatment they gave her like chances
they asked her please and and from what
i've heard too she agreed
to reign some of this stuff in at a
certain point i'm like well
you made your bed like you knew what the
situation was and
yeah you know you got bit for it and
that's the thing yes
consequences don't negate freedoms
they're just
what happens next i mean people have
been let go in the pet
like it wouldn't happen today but in the
past maybe it would happen today i just
don't think it would
but in the past people have been like go
just for being gay or
publicly coming out as being gay in
hollywood you know there's always
some type of political agenda that's
kind of happening in hollywood and in
large parts of the world and other
businesses just some of them are not as
public about it yeah and for better or
for worse sometimes you know
so here's my thing on it this is not my
call i personally was able to still
watch the mandalorian and not be like
i never i was never distracted by
her personal life image there are times
where gina carano does show up online
and she's like hey you know
lots of people who i got love for i hate
bullying stuff like that
and there there's been plenty of times
where she has supported like good causes
and such yeah so yeah problematic
character
in real life in my opinion i don't know
that's the thing is like i don't really
know and i know that there are people
who are very near and dear to me
who would not like me saying i don't
know that they'd want me to fall on a
particular side it's that thing of no i
don't agree with gina carrano on the
thing she's
said and done the question comes down to
should she have been fired
and so i'm like well i i don't
i don't know it makes sense it's not
surprising
but for my personal viewership i wasn't
distracted
you know yeah i don't pay attention
enough to what gina carano is doing in
real life
and i don't really know what level of
influence the the level of things she
was
sharing did it cause rise to any was
there anything that like
she was helping radically yeah anybody i
mean
by putting your opinion out you are
right like
whatever opinion you put out to someone
if you have followers and you
and people feel supported by your
opinion that you're putting out
you're automatically throwing fuel on
whatever fire of the side you you fall
on right i just don't know how dangerous
it was
if it was dangerous or what she was
doing yeah or if it's just yeah
just like severely kind of uh poorly
based
car dude's a character i've always been
like yeah she's all right uh i'm never
in love with cara dune i've always
thought junior
was okay i guess that's also probably
why i would never really
like bother because i'm like carter's
never really been my favorite and
she's kind of just there for her
physicality and some people really love
her portrayal there are people who
love the [ __ ] out of her portrayal i
personally have always been like
whatever uh she's cool you know i like
her in the ensemble i wouldn't
necessarily be like give me a card dude
where's the rangers of the new republic
show i don't want that like you better
be friends
that never excited me uh but in terms of
like
a few appearances here or there in a
given season i was like yeah she's fine
pretty yeah pretty tough you know i like
the chemistry of mando and all that yeah
no there's a real solid conclusion here
because everyone seems to either have
like a really solid like
everyone's heated up they're either
outraged by it or
good writing vehemently like well done
disney
and i'm more like
this was a choice i'm not surprised you
know any choice out of a few different
choices
yeah i'm not sure we'll contribute to
the conversation here you know we're
contributing the ability to address
these
ideas without losing our minds to
vitriol
and anger and frustration and just the
cultural angst that seems to underlie
a lot of stuff especially on social
media right now my bottom line point to
all this no one should have been
surprised by this
disney clearly at least the public image
they point out for all i know bob iger
and all them are like
really hardcore trump supporters yeah
like what the public wants us to not be
you know like me with the money
exactly exactly you know at the end of
the day they're tending to what brings
them the most money none of this is
surprising
it's not like i don't think you're a mew
if i if i go out there
and i say i fully support joe biden i
hate donald trump i'm gonna get a whole
bunch of people mad at me any celebrity
who does it they still get a lot of crap
the thing though is it's the way the
world is right now when it comes to
disney yeah
they're left-leaning she's not yeah was
it right
you guys decided you guys argue about it
yeah they made up their minds it's
within their right and their freedom to
fire her if they want though
so she can go wear not masks with bruce
willis or something
you know she can go to a clint eastwood
joint i mean he's outspokenly right-wing
and he's still working
so i mean he doesn't post takes like
this
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below
talk to you guys soon